so we're going to begin with breaking
news from northern Pakistan eight people
who were trapped in a cable car
suspended 300 meters above the ground
have been rescued they've been dangling
for hours after one of the cables
snapped the incident occurred when they
were above a remote Mountain Valley in
Cabo Park in Province Kamal Haider is
joining us now from Islamabad the
reaction one would imagine must be of
immense relief talk us through what the
latest is on the rescue operation
will indeed relief across the country
this was a massive effort that involved
not just the military but the local
expertise Brave volunteers from the
local area as well after the reports of
that incident took place in the morning
spread throughout the country there was
a frantic call for helicopters to come
to the rescue those helicopters tried
frantically to reach the cable car which
was suspended on it tilting onto a side
after those cables gave way some food
supplies and water were dropped by the
military with great difficulty they were
able to get at least one of those
children out via helicopter however the
military also asked for local help
experts from the area who are in the
know-how about how these cables operate
how these cable cars operate were
brought in it was a huge effort and
after dark the military helicopter
rescue mission was halted but the
military is still in command and along
with the locals then they were able to
improvise the smaller trolley that was
first able to get some food over to them
as long along with water and then one by
one were able to bring those people out
from that suspended uh trolley several
hundred feet above ground level so
indeed a dating operation by the
military by the locals as well and a
sigh of relief across the country
because all day long people across
Pakistan have been praying for those
children and their teacher who was on
board that
trolley or cable car so indeed a major
rescue effort which has finally paid off
yeah just as you're talking to us we're
looking at some of the pictures of the
the extraordinary efforts that have gone
into to finally getting all eight people
off that cable car one would imagine now
that in amongst all the relief an
investigation of some sort must have to
be held into what actually happened and
how to stop it happening again
absolutely the Pakistani interim prime
minister and water Cocker issued a
notification uh putting a ban on all
such uh
um basically cable cars that were
operating in the area and said that
there was a need for strict control uh
this is something that was organized by
the locals because of the difficulties
they faced there are no Bridges to cut
distances and therefore people have to
improvise so most of the locals use this
kind of Transport in order to cut
distance and time this is something
which is quite common in the hybrid
Province and gilgart baltistan and so
the locals of course were in the
know-how they used the same cable on
which that cable car was dangling to be
able to organize a smaller trolley that
was then able to go across and help
those people so
Ingenuity on part of the local people a
great effort by the military and also
now I question as to how this could have
happened why wasn't there any local
control why wasn't the local
Administration aware that these things
were happening and the risk it entailed
because uh it should be remembered that
this particular cable car was carrying
several hundred students on a daily
basis
and this tragedy of course happening in
the morning but this of course has
highlighted the dangers of unregulated
activity the government of course has to
now pay attention the Prime Minister
taking notice of it as well and everyone
here will be hoping that they will be
Lessons Learned and not like in the past
when it is forgotten and then again such
activities continue once more Kamal
thank you very much indeed Kamal khaida
talking to us from Islamabad